[Musique]
la chine représente 19% des 7 milliards
d'habitants de la planète leurs terres
cultivables sont limitées et 20% d'entre
elles sont pollués la petite cet état
est grandissant ces dernières années le
pays a acquis 10 millions d'hectares
dans le monde on a vu après la crise
alimentaire de 2007 quand les prises
alimentaires ont vraiment augmenté dans
le monde et les pays qui exportent des
denrées alimentaires ils ont fermé la
frontière que tout d'un coup des pays
qui dépend de l'extérieur pour
s'alimenter comme la chine la corée du
sud et pays du golfe la libye ils
pouvaient plus acheter de nourriture
pour la population ils ont commencé à se
dire au lieu de dépendre des marchés
pour acheter des denrées agricoles
il allait chercher à prendre compte au
delà terres en afrique en asie en
amérique latine pour faire le propre
production agricole pour avoir plus de
contrôle
comment on peut acheter 900 hectares
sans avoir de comptes à rendre à
personne alors que le gars qui vend 50
hectares ou qui en achète 50 hectares on
lui demande d'apporter des garanties sur
si vous sur sas etc
[Musique]
et
non
quand on regarde l'histoire des lois sur
le français c'est un peu l'histoire de
l'après-guerre
on considère à l'époque et à juste titre
que le marché du foncier que le foncier
n'est pas une marchandise comme le
foncier ne peut pas être une marchandise
comme les autres parce qu'il détient
non seulement la nourriture des hommes
et on le sait aujourd'hui une part de la
solution au changement climatique
il est la clé de notre assurance vie que
la biodiversité il participe à la paix
du monde simplement est la survie et à
la paix du monde donc la terre comme un
commun la terre comme quelque chose qui
doit être régulée un marché qui n'a
presque pas marché libéral a marché
sauvage et ont créé les organismes de
régulation et surtout en créer un
une capacité d'intervention publique à
travers les safer qui peuvent intervenir
sur le marché pour le réguler la terre
doit aller à ceux qui en ont besoin
[Musique]
la première réaction c'était une vraie
surprise parce qu'on n'imaginait pas que
des chinois puissent acquérir un
ensemble d'exploitation en france
justement sans qu'on soit au courant
sans qu'on ait la moindre notification
alors que la règle depuis depuis 1960
c'est que en france tout transfert de
foncier agricole doit être notifiée à la
safer pour que je puisse cavard
justement un contrôle sur l'utilisation
sûre qu'ils achètent sur son prix
la safer est un organisme de régulation
et peut être sollicitée par des
agriculteurs
lorsqu il y à une vente de terrains et
rien de vente de terrains je suis
intéressé jeudi j'achète ce terrain mais
au moment de passer devant le notaire le
notaire doit donner une information et
peut-être que ces terrains que je me
propose d'acheter et bien conviendront
mieux
un jeune agriculteur qui a une faible
surface et qui doit s'agrandir plutôt
qu'à moi qui exploite déjà par exemple
une grande surface dont la safer a la
possibilité de se substituer à
l'acquéreur pour ensuite rétrocédé ses
pairs à un autre acquéreur
en l'occurrence dans la vente des
terrains à ce consortium chinois il ne
s'agit pas de vendre des terres on vend
une part de sociétés on va une part de
sociétés c'est à dire que les terres
sont inclus dans la société dans le
capital d'exploitation avec les
bâtiments avec le matériel etc
c est donc la loi prévoit que la safer
contrairement à l'exemple que je donnais
tout à l'heure ne peut pas intervenir
s'il n'ya pas cession de la totalité des
parts et donc
l'astuce pour dans les montages
financiers c'est finalement est bien de
ne céder que 98 ou 99 % des parts il
suffit de garder un ou deux pourcent et
cette vente échappe totalement à la
régulation que la safer peu peut en
faire les chinois ils ont simplement été
les précurseurs c'est à dire qu'ils se
sont infiltrés dans une dans un détail
de la loi car ils sont très bien
conseillé et de ce fait ils ont créé des
sociétés pour pouvoir contourner la
safer mais on les a regardés monsieur
c'était des chinois mais on a des bons
berrichon qui n'ont pas les yeux
et qu'ils ont compris aussi qu'il y
avait une faille qui la laisse sans
filtre est dedans et aujourd'hui il ya
le même montage sociétal fait part des
berrichons pour s'accaparer des terres
sans avoir de comptes à rendre à la
safer à la commission départementale
des structures
[Musique]